[Music]
let me ask you a question
who will you call when the police have
been defunded
and dismantled take a look hello
you've reached 911. i'm sorry that there
is no one here to answer your emergency
call
but leave a message and we'll get back
to you as soon as we can
here with reaction fox news contributor
dan bongino host of the reuben report
dave rubin dave let me start with you
tonight
what's interesting a couple of incidents
happened this weekend i'll tell you
about a case in portland
an african-american man with an american
flag
stands against the protesters tearing
down a fence
then an african-american woman dumped
paint on
one of the black lives matters a couple
of the murals in new york city
we wanna our police refund the police
sort of like
with goya you know there was the boycott
then there was the mycot that i support
i don't support boycotts
that to me tells me a lot because now
this
this entire race has pivoted safety
security
radical socialism radical
environmentalism
versus free market capitalism in the and
the great economy donald trump created
well it's crazy to think about but that
really is what this has boiled down and
you know i did a little googling before
the show
and sean you were born in new york city
i know dan was born in
queens and i was born in brooklyn okay
so you got the three boroughs right
there there is no
uh panel on television that loves the
great city of new york more than the
three of us right
and do we want federal troops in new
york of course we don't but if the mayor
himself de blasio and by the way this
goes of course for the mayors
of los angeles chicago and a couple of
the other cities you mentioned if they
won't do
their jobs then trump has got to do
something and we discussed it a couple
weeks ago maybe
partly what the progressive mayors are
doing here is laying a trap so that
trump puts
you know puts law enforcement in their
federal officers
so that it makes him look like the
authoritarian that they want him to look
like but i think the average person
if it's either my city is going to burn
or we're going to have to send the feds
in to
to fix it they will choose the side of
law and order
and you know just think back to what it
was new york city was like before mayor
giuliani i'm sure
many people remember david dinkins who
was the progressive and the entire city
was a disaster and crime and drugs in
times square
it became a joke everybody knows about
it and then what did giuliani do
he came in he cleaned it up and and new
york had about 15
great years so it can be fixed but
politicians have to have the will to do
it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell